évidemment sur l'agression dont a fait
l'objet le philosophe et académicien
alain finkielkraut celui ci revient dans
le figaro de ce matin sur ce qui s'est
passé
il rappelle que les gens qui l'ont
agressé on criait palestine qui l'on
traitait de sionistes il y en avait 1
avec une légère barbe qui m'a dit dieu
va te punir ce n'est pas tout à fait le
langage de l'extrême droite
c'est même la rhétorique islamistes
alors toute la question est de savoir si
dans ce mouvement il y a un certain
nombre d'extrémistes de tout bord ou
bien seulement ceux d'un camp je vous
propose d'écouter deux points de vue
assez différent au sein même du
gouvernement d'abord on va écouter jean
michel blanquer rc le ministre de
l'éducation nationale il était ce matin
sur france info
et pour lui c'est clair l'antisémitisme
il a changé de camp si vous faites de
l'histoire des idées au début du 20e
siècle vous avez eu des des grands
leaders de gauche qui était qui était
d'antisémite et au moment de l' affaire
dreyfus
vous ne vous inquiétez pas gauche contre
droite c'était l'antisémitisme ne
pouvait diviser et la gauche et la
droite donc il ya évidemment des racines
d'antisémite aussi à gauche et on l'est
on le voit bien hall de nos jours et
d'ailleurs je dirais qu'aujourd'hui
l'antisémitisme et se manifeste de
manière particulièrement inquiétante à
l'extrême gauche alors maintenant on va
écouter un autre membre du gouvernement
agnès buzyn la ministre de la santé
elle était hier sur lci et elle a
attaqué assez vivement
marine le pen marine le pen a condamné
l'agression n'ont pas fait l'objet alain
finkielkraut
mais pour la ministre de la santé la
patronne du rassemblement national joue
double jeu
elle joue sur l'ambiguïté elle mange à
tous les râteliers donc aller contre
l'antisémitisme mais elle a plein de néo
nazis dans son entourage
et dès qu'elle peut aller en autriche où
un à bruxelles avec tous les néo nazis
où les mouvements d'extrême droite
d'europe et du monde entier et les cours
donc elle mange à tous les râteliers
c'est ce que j'ai à dire aujourd'hui
voilà introduction un peu longue mais
c'était pour poser les enjeux du sujet
nicolas baverez
est-ce que cet antisémitisme qui renaît
c'est un antisémitisme que l'on voit
notamment dans le mouvement des gilet
jaune est ce qu'il vient d'un seul camp
où est ce que il est l'expression d'une
sorte d'hybridation entre l'extrême
droite et l'extrême gauche je le crois
d'abord que si on regarde les faits donc
ce qui est arrivé alain finkielkraut
très clairement le type même des
insultes qu'ils ont été adressés ça
venait effectivement de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'islamo gauchisme le
ministère de l'intérieur à d'ailleurs
dit que 1 des hommes avaient été
identifiés et qu'ils étaient proches des
milieux salah voilà alors sur les gilets
jaunes en général c'est vrai que ça
n'est pas seulement l'extrême gauche
puis on voit que ce mouvement qui au
départ était un mouvement beaucoup plus
large et qui a rassemblé des gens assez
différent progressivement devient de
plus en plus radicale et fusionne des
extrémistes de gauche c'est des
extrémistes de droite maintenant sur
l'antisémitisme si on cherche
d'interpréter au delà de ces faits il
est certain que on a à la fois de
l'extrême gauche de l'extrême droite et
du facteur religieux simplement la
religion aujourd'hui c'est plus le
catholicisme comme au début dû à la fin
du 19e siècle au temps de l'affairé
dreyfus c'est ça vient surtout du monde
monde musulman donc là il ya une
pathologie française j'allais dire des
intellectuels français puisque le
personnage du musulman où le personnage
du palestinien april a remplacé le
prolétaire dans depuis la fin de l'union
soviétique et le déclin du marxisme
comme le héros des opprimés et le
vecteur de la révolution et a quand même
là aussi une analyse plus large qui
touche toutes les démocraties puisque
l'antisémitisme n'est pas une
spécificité française on le voit partout
en europe 1 ch de chez urban mais aussi
dans le lait beurre de jeremy corbyn on
le voit aux états unis avec l'attentât
de pittsburgh
et là aussi le regain d actes
antisémites donc derrière il faut bien
voir qu'il ya une crise de la démocratie
que comme à la fin du 19e siècle comme
dans les années 30 un des baromètres de
la crise de la démocratie c'est le
regain de l'antisémitisme parce que
c'est ce qui fédère le sentiment qu'ils
élite le sentiment anti capitaliste le
sentiment anti cosmopolite et qui
fusionne finalement les crises
économiques et sociales et puis les
crises identitaires
je n avais qu est-ce qu on peut dire que
cet antisémitisme qui renaît il ya une
augmentation très forte du nombre
d'actes l'année dernière il vient de
l'extrême gauche
non alors d'avoir la première chose que
je veux dire c'est que il faudrait
cesser de trouver à chaque semaine un
nouveau moyen pour discréditer le
mouvement des jeunes que je le rappelle
est soutenu par la majorité absolue des
français donc des gens qui sont de
gauche de droite il ya sûrement des gens
d'extrême droite ya sûrement des gens
d'extrême gauche et bien sûr qu'il faut
condamner les comportements comme cette
personne que je suis à peu près sûr
qu'il n'est pas gauchiste puisque il est
visiblement ils étaient fichés s dont il
fait partie des franges qui à une époque
extrêmement dur dont j'ai des gens puis
donc très conservateur dans l'islam
qu'on peut difficilement qualifier de
gauche vous dirai par exemple de vous
avez parlé de
de la france insoumise je peux vous
assurez la j'ai beaucoup de critiques
justement je ne suis pas d'accord avec
les problèmes de rapprochement était
certaines thèses communautarisme et je
peux vous assurer que personne liée
antisémite on peut broder autant qu'on
veut ce que vous pouvez avoir c'est une
crainte de ne pas critiquer et ne
veulent pas critiquer certains
islamistes parce qu'ils le sont
réellement
certains sont réellement antisémite
parce que ce serait le poser un problème
pour les luttes contre le racisme mais
ça c'est juste que je sais tout et rien
d'autre et dans votre votre tableau que
vous avez dressé qui est qui et qui est
assez juste vous amuse en oublier un
quand même et qui est celui de qui
institutionnels
je ne sais pas pourquoi mais alors que
l'antisémitisme est un est un véritable
souci ça ne nous pose pas problème quand
ça se passe dans les pays d'europe de
l'est
c'est pas grave il n'y a aucune
indignation quand des pays baltes
érigent des monuments à laval il n'y a
aucun problème quand on reçoit monsieur
parent ou me absolument prêt venus
d'ukraine qui a fondé un parti social
nationaliste qui donc avec nos dents le
symbole était quand même là celui de la
division das reich celui qui a rasé
oradour sur glane oradour sur glane et
qu'on reçoit au parlement ce diamètre
aucune critique avant ce monsieur
françois hollande qui avait reçu
monsieur thiam n'évoque qui était comme
quand même considéré par les états unis
interdit sur le territoire parce que
ultra antisémite
donc moi on a on a un problème c'est que
chacun instrumentalise comme comme ça l
arrange en écosse à l'abri des
ministères français donc forcément on se
sent plus ou moins ménagés
il ya déjà des atteintes des actes
antisémites en dehors du monde et gilet
jaune malheureusement notre jour cette
grande dame qu'adam simone veil qui est
d'entre portée nationale a été lavé les
images a été non quelqu'un a dessiné des
croix nazies ont du mal à imaginer que
d'un gauchiste dessine des drogues mais
enfin ça va vous faudra appeler quand
même que dans l'histoire
de ce siècle l'extrême droite critiquer
ceux qui étaient de gauche parce que
c'était une sorte de communisme dans un
sorte de complot juif et avec lénine qui
avait marqué et trotsky puis le bund
enfin bref
donc on peut pas non je suis pas
d'accord même si si j'ai plein de
conflits je refuse de qualifier tout le
monde d'antisémite ce serait tout à fait
ce que je voulais de la france a
soumises il s'est simplement citer une
phrase de votre tribune je crois à
marianne dans lequel vous expliquer que
la france insoumise nier le problème
posé par l'islamisme et vous n'étiez pas
aller plus loin que cela dans votre
propos judith waintraub moi je ne sais
pas si des responsables de haut niveau
de la france a ainsi misé sont
antisémites j'observe que ce week end
ceux qui se sont manifestés le plus sur
les réseaux sociaux ont par exemple dit
comme aude lancelin qui est la patronne
du média télé proche de jean luc
mélenchon que finkielkraut et et un
incitateur allen public un agent
provocateur
j'ai aussi noté thomas guénolé qui
accusé alain finkielkraut
on le voit d'ailleurs de répandre la
haine en france des prises de position à
l'exception de clémentine autain qui a
juste pris la précaution de dire qu'elle
ne partageait pas les idées de
figuerolles krauth des tweets et des
réactions qui si ils ne signent pas de
l'antisémitisme témoigne au mois dany
slam au gauchisme assumée et revendiquée
je dirais presque revendiqué on peut
faire l'histoire et l'histoire c'est
exactement ce que vous avez dit il ya eu
un antisémitisme d'extrême droite
aujourd'hui l'antisémitisme qui tue et
qui a tué notamment les 13 juifs qui ont
été tués parce que juif depuis 2003 et
d'anti c'est bien ce sont des crimes
perpétrés tous phares des
arabo-musulmans tous et pas un seul
crime contre un juif qui est tué un juif
à venir à l'inter cacher treize
personnes
ouais on peut faire la liste ici il y en
a pas un seul
ce qui fait qu'il ya plus de boom juifs
d'enfants juifs dans les écoles
publiques de seine saint denis s'est pas
non plus des enfants d'extrême droite
donc il faut quand même avoir une
approche je pense pragmatique et
efficace de la question et si on combat
l'antisémitisme sans vouloir l'éradiquer
parce que ça nous sommes totalement
impossible c'est quand même une
constante à travers les alpes
si on combat les conséquences les plus
sanglantes de l'antisémitisme il faut
savoir ce qu'on combat est ce qu'on
combat cessa car s'il est très
surprenant de voir que malgré tout ce
qui s'est passé malgré le procès de
georges bensoussan le fait qu'il ait
gagné ce procès bonjour je rappelle que
georges bensoussan est passé devant le
tribunal correctionnel puis en appel
c'est lui qui avait écrit qu'il veut
diriger d'abord se livrent les
territoires perdus de la république puis
la suite une france soumise exact
courage auquel vous avez fait exactement
alors les territoires perdus de la
république c'était en 2002 pourquoi ce
livre parce que en 2000 il ya eu une
augmentation de plus de 900 pour 900 %
des agressions antisémites entre 1999 et
2000 à l'occasion de la deuxième
intifada et depuis 2000 le nombre
d'actes antisémites est resté très haut
ya des fluctuations bientôt on est passé
de 900 à 520 est monté à 600 à 800 mhz
et c'est très haut et judith waintraub a
raison a rappelé que ces actes
antisémites 6 à ces agressions contre
des personnes antisémite c'est
principalement majoritairement très très
majoritairement des islamistes encore là
ce n'est pas ce ne sont pas des islamo
gauchiste léger les jeunes n'y sont pour
rien l'extrême droite n'y est pour rien
non plus il ya probablement des
antisémites chez les gens d'extrême
droite mais de notre culture profonde en
france
l'antisémitisme suscite l'indignation le
problème ce sont ces populations
islamiste qui se réclame d'une culture
de pays où la xénophobie le racisme et
l'antisémitisme ne sont pas des
problèmes car ce ne sont pas des délits
et où il est complètement désinhibé
voilà le problème il est là et lutter
contre l'antisémitisme c'est quoi ce
n'est pas prendre chaque antisémite qui
est sûr en france et le trépané c'est
s'assurer que dans l'identité culturelle
de la france dans la décence commune de
notre pays
l'antisémitisme suicide de l'indignation
or dans certains territoires et le livre
une france famille des voix du refus que
j'ai coécrit et qui était dit
j'ai par georges bensoussan confirmant
en réalité que dans ces territoires être
antisémite
ce n'est pas mal c'est même bien et je
dirais même que si vous n'êtes pas
antisémite vous n'êtes pas acceptée par
la meute
donc c'est ça le problème mais ne savait
quoi on a énormément de problèmes à le
condamner cet antisémitisme là encore
aujourd'hui regardez blanc caire
bancaire à tort je les aime beaucoup
mais blanquer rathor il a encore cette
ip restés divisés vie l'antisémitisme
traditionnel de droite franco-français
et cette hypocrisie des habits de
l'antisémitisme islamistes qui
n'arrivent pas à condamner
aujourd'hui ce qu'on en attend à ce que
l'on n'obtient pas c'est une vraie
politique contre cet antisémitisme
spécifique qui est celui des arabo
musulman fondamentaliste des territoires
perdus c'est à dire qu'on leur dise vous
êtes antisémites et ça ne va pas je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi en france n'est
pas possible de l'être
pourquoi c'est mal et pourquoi si vous
continuer à l'être vous ne pourrez
jamais vous intégrer dans notre société
or aucun président aucun premier
ministre et aucun des responsables
politiques qui au temps nous tous au
bout d'un moment passé d'un goût un
gouvernement quelconque au cours des
vingt trente ou quarante dernières
années et qui votent retrouvait la
manifestation contre l'antisémitisme de
demain et le courage de faire ça et ça
c'est inacceptable en france
oui nicolas pas failli à une une
manifestation qui est organisée demain
contre l'antisémitisme
le président la république annoncé qu'il
ne s'y rendrait pas vous pensez que
c'était la bonne décision star qu'il ne
faut pas que le chef de l'état se se
défendent ainsi dans l'arène même si il
va a participé mercredi soir au dîner du
crif le conseil représentatif des
institutions juives de france
dîner au cours duquel il prendra la
parole au président de la république qui
fait d'eux des bas de sept heures par
semaine
non la france dans différentes régions
donc c'est difficile d'expliquer qu'il
ne faut pas qu'ils descendent dans
l'arène
donc c'est toujours la même chose la
place du président de la république dans
une manifestation
ça veut dire qu'il se passe quelque
chose de grave
donc soit on considère que ce qui se
passe est grave et je crois que c'est le
cas et sa place est là soit on considère
que ça n'est qu'un fait divers parmi
d'autres et à ce moment là
il est dans le jeu normal du chef de
l'état théoriquement au dessus des
partis
même si c'est de moins en moins de moins
en moins le cas je crois que ce qui a
été dit pour ma part je le rejoins
chacun a défendu un peu mais voyez le
jeu j'avais bien indiqué le organes d'un
côté corps been de l'autre ça montre
bien que aujourd'hui on peut dire que
c'est plus à droite ou plus à gauche je
ne sais pas ça existe dans les deux
camps et par ailleurs comme je le billet
sur le plan religieux
il est certain que on a une effective
mans la communauté arabo musulmane est
largement contaminé par l'antisémitisme
c'est une situation qui à mon avis est
très dangereuse elle est très dangereuse
évidemment en tant que tel mais aussi
parce qu'on sait que je le répète
l'antisémitisme c'est toujours la pointe
avancée de la destruction de la
démocratie et de la république
c'est pour ça qu'à mon avis si on
considère que le président de la
république et non seulement le chef de
l'état mais le garant d'un certain
nombre de valeurs est le garant de la
république
on peut se dire que dans ces
circonstances sa place était sans doute
dans 7 meilleurs concours vous
regrettiez que qu'il décide de ne pas y
aller je vais vous donner la parole
caroline valentin je voudrais simplement
la donne et aussi à nos internautes
vous pouvez bien sûr intervenir à la
fois sur twitter sur lefigaro.fr
je vous donne cette réflexion de nicole
qui nous dit on sait d'où vient
l'antisémitisme en france mais là bien
pensants s'obstine à parler d'extrême
droite
sheldon nous parle de ce prof d'histoire
qui ne peuvent pas aborder la shoah dans
certains collèges de région parisienne
il nous dit aussi et je pense que
j'écoute mon avis ne sera pas d'accord
besancenot est la france insoumise
refont le conflit israélo-palestinien
sur notre territoire
romain dit macron devrait devait macron
devait rassembler apaisé après vingt
mois il a juste jeter de l'huile sur le
feu sur tous les sujets exacerbant
toutes les violences
caroline valentin voulu ajouter quelque
chose oui je veux ajouter quelque chose
est-ce que c'était la rolls de mâcon
devient à cette manifestation de demain
peut-être pas avec le ps de de françois
hollande ou de hamon qui ne fait que
servir la soupe aux islamistes
peut-être peut-être pas non plus avec
europe ecologie les verts dont on peut
dire la même chose peut-être même pas
avec son propre mouvement en marche
jusque on a vu très récemment que rien
rien tâche et qui représente la laïcité
ouverte plutôt la non laïcité en fait
l'a emporté sur le lake blanc caire
puisqu'il a obtenu que blanc caire
retire son soutien à l'amendement ciotti
qui visait à interdire les mères voilées
aux sorties scolaires alors que c'est
très symbolique et une fois de plus dans
une france où mis des voitures furent on
voit à quel point derrière ce mouvement
d'amy qui voulaient des mères voilées
aux sorties scolaires il ya les
islamistes mais je pourquoi ans qu'en
fait on n'a aucun responsable politique
qui s'attaque à ce problème parce que ce
n'est pas tout les musulmans un caisson
est ministre et tous les amis sont en
tissu sont antisémites et c'est même
limite à ça qu'on les reconnaît
sauf que c'est 10 % des français et 10 %
c'est beaucoup un beau coup en terme
électoral
c'est beaucoup plus que des moins de 500
milles jeu il faut qu'on prenne et je
crois que ceux qui n'ont pas compris ce
qu'il faudrait qu'ils comprennent c'est
que l'essai l'antisémitisme se dérouler
et voilà quand on a un islam is ya assez
extrêmes note assez léger les jaunes à
c'est tout le monde sauf les musulmans
parce qu'on ne peut pas leur dire parce
qu'on n'ose pas le faire et bien c'est
renier tout ce que la france est censée
représenter tout ce qu'elle est censée
incarner
vous avez dit sur le monde de coups de
courage à madame valentin des danses et
les les islamistes sont des ennemis
république puisque ce sont des gens qui
font passer le fait religieux quels que
soient leur fait religieux avant les
valeurs de la république mais néanmoins
je voulais rappeler qu' il faut arrêter
d'utiliser le
l'antisémitisme est de lui la colle et
comment on fait en ce moment on tente de
le faire avec l'ensemble des gilet jaune
j'ai pas dis ici
carlo endroit est effectivement pour les
pour les questions électorales
en fait c'est une erreur puisque là une
très très grande partie des musulmans de
france dans les élections blanc-mesnil
récemment ont récemment dans l'essonne
cette ligne communautariste à valoriser
ou ne pas opposer à dire quoi que ce
soit aux groupes salafistes religieux
dans les quartiers mais n'a en fait même
à des défaites mais ce qui n'est pas
bien non plus et que le président de la
république je les aie du crif s'est
aussi nicoletta rythme ce ne sont pas
les représentants des juifs de france et
l'organisation des l'économique et de
l'extrême droite
une fois de la très très droite
israélienne qui dev qui défend des
intérêts particuliers pourquoi pas mais
le président n'a rien à faire là n'a pas
allé parler aux évêques de france n'a
pas aller à fond pour le pain qu avec
avec à la fin du ramadan il y défend les
valeurs de la république et la laïcité
qu'il n'a rien à faire là bas on veut
aller dans la rue
plus tôt on va continuer à parler de ce
sujet mais mes prix sous un autre angle
puisque il ya cette initiative sur
laquelle j'aimerais avoir votre point de
vue d'une trentaine de députés emmenés
par sylvain maillard député de la
république en marche qui souhaitent
d'interdire l'antisionisme en fait de
deux d'assimiler l'anti sionisme qui est
donc l'opposition à l'état d'israël
voire à son existence de l'associer